I'm an astrophysicist at a major
university science is my life
but when I hear somebody somberly in
tone science says or follow the science
I get very nervous science doesn't
belong to any ideology science is the
never-ending search for new knowledge
that's what science means in Latin by
the way knowledge not wisdom not
morality not social policy knowledge but
we do with that knowledge is where
wisdom morality and social policy enter
the picture
knowledge it turns out isn't so easy to
come by and sometimes what we think we
know for certain the Earth sure does
look flat when we're standing on it
turns out not to be so certain
of course I trust in basic scientific
truths those things for which there is
overwhelming evidence like say gravity
even that humans play a role in the
warming of the planet but scientists
even the best ones can get things wrong
the brilliant astrophysicist sir Fred
Hoyle believed the universe existed in a
steady state forever and had no
beginning
but his view once held sacrosanct by all
astrophysicists no longer halts it's
been superseded by the big bang theory
that the Universe had a beginning and is
still expanding in the 20th century some
of the most respective scientists in the
world including Nobel Prize winners
believe the Eugenics the reprehensible
idea that the human race could be
improved by selective breeding the
National Academy of Sciences the
American Medical Association and the
Rockefeller Foundation supported it
by the middle of the century it had been
thoroughly rejected as quackery no
reputable scientists would have anything
to do with this idea
so we all need to get over this notion
that just because someone be it a
politician a bureaucrat or even a
scientist employs the phrase science
says means whatever they're saying is
right
it might be right but it might also be
wrong
and if it's wrong it won't necessarily
be a bunch of scientists who say it's
wrong it might be one guy
ask Einstein 100 scientists wrote a book
explaining why his theory of relativity
was wrong equipped if I were wrong then
one would have been enough
it takes a lot to convince scientists to
accept a new Theory especially if that
new Theory refutes what they had always
believed in some cases what they'd stake
their entire careers on as Richard
Feynman one of the most eminent
physicists of the 20th century famously
said science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts what Feynman is
saying is that a good scientist should
always maintain a healthy amount of
skepticism science is by its nature
provisional science would stagnate if we
merely accepted proclamations of past
authorities
so how do we do good science
this is not a new question
since the 17th century scientists have
employed the so-called scientific method
to guide their work it's not a perfect
guide by any means but it's pretty darn
good
the method involves one formulating a
theory two predicting the evidence that
should be found if the theory is true
three collecting data four analyzing the
data five refining the theory and
presenting evidence to other experts
the philosopher Carl popper added one
more item to this list popper said a
subject is scientific if and only if it
can be falsified
in other words if your theory can't be
tested if it can't be proven wrong it's
probably not good science
this is just one reason why we have to
be very careful about putting too much
faith in models they often can't be
tested
models are predictions of the future
based on current data they can easily
get things wrong
first of all the future in case you
hadn't noticed is very hard to predict
and the further out you go into the
future the less secure the prediction
second the data may be incomplete or
even erroneous
it's human nature to want definitive
answers but science can't always offer
those
furthermore science is not concerned
with fashion Authority or majority
opinion
Case Closed is not a scientific
expression
science is never closed if it was closed
after Newton you'd never have Einstein
science has to be first and always about
pursuing knowledge not about advancing a
social agenda no matter how Noble it
might be
science has no political party
of course politicians should use the
best available signs to help them make
informed decisions
but remember scientific knowledge is not
the same as wisdom
as the saying goes knowledge is knowing
a tomato is a fruit wisdom is knowing
not to put it in a fruit salad so let's
continue to look to science for
knowledge knowledge we can use to
improve the world but let's not fool
ourselves that science has all the
answers to all our problems it doesn't
that's one bit of wisdom this scientist
can give you
I'm Brian Keating professor of physics
at the University of California San
Diego and author of losing the Nobel
Prize for Prager University
thank you for watching this video to
keep prageru videos free please consider
making a tax deductible donation